joining me now is zach kriegman former
data scientist at thomson reuters zach
explain for the audience
what happened
when you brought the data
to your boss
um yeah thanks for having me on laura
so basically what happened was i had
been following this uh the research
coming out of major universities and i'd
compiled it into a summary and i posted
that to our internal
collaboration platform to start to try
to build some kind of discussion around
the fact that you know what we were
reporting um
to the public and what we were you know
in the and the assumptions that we had
within the company
just did not match the data
and when i
posted that on our internal message
forms to try to get that conversation
started
what happened was it immediately made me
the target of a barrage of
really intensely hateful
and ultimately racialized attacks
and then the company's reaction to that
was basically just to shut down
you know to censor everything that i'd
written censor any kind of criticism of
the black lives matter movement and shut
down the conversation
um
so you weren't you were just bringing
the actual
facts though or were you editorializing
on the facts were you telling them this
was the number
that
that i came up with without a political
commentary
no it what it really wasn't a political
commentary it was really just focusing
on the facts so i took i looked at
statistics from the government i looked
at the best studies uh probably the best
one coming out of harvard by one of the
most uh you know a very famous and
well-respected um researcher roland
fryer
that still stands as probably the best
study on
police
bias in lethal shootings
and i was really just trying to put
together the whole
the whole
picture that's coming out of these
research institutions um
and
yeah no one wanted to hear it
well i want to play for you um
what the co-founder blm the movement
said today
addressing her mounting financial
scandals watch
the way that the
right-wing media specifically has
characterized the mistakes are truly
anti-black they are about
this idea that black people especially
black women don't know how to manage
money don't have to manage funds don't
know what to do with money
and
the reality is if any organization
received
tens of millions of dollars in one to
two months time
everybody would be trying to figure out
what you do with it
well zach there seems to have been a
circling the wagons uh for blm when's
this news started to trickle out
and it seems to happen in corporate
america as well
yeah
i mean it's really i
it's really not surprising in a sense
like the the ethical sort of failures
that would lead to sort of spreading
these lies about police bias seem like
the exact same ethical failures that
would lead to these massive financial
scandals where millions some people are
saying billions of dollars are
unaccounted for in the various
organizations
um but it's not you know it's in a sense
it's not surprising that you would have
activists i think there's activists of
all strip political stripes who are
probably unethical what's the problem to
me is is
that uh our media institutions and our
other social institutions raised these
activists up um and promoted their
messages
um without without questioning exactly
without any exact questioning
no accountability
i mean what's amazing is and zach i
don't mean to interrupt you but but you
actually were bringing data to the
equation the science and data people
right they don't want to hear the
science and data they're not interested
in it unless it advances their
particular narrative i'm really sorry
about what happened to you zach your
story is an important one to tell thank
you